big bastard wasn't he
nicely done keep an eye out for that
creepy red one
i don't want to get interrupted wait
what that's it it's that little thing
the hell did
oh
oh my god
i get it i understand
i understand everything
hey a handsome
i'm gonna kill her
i'm gonna kill them all
oh first you're gonna find me a doctor
then we're gonna wipe those banded
bastards off the face of pandora
and then then we're gonna wake the
warrior
the what it's gonna be so
good we're gonna scorch the freaking
planet in
fire there's gonna be screaming
bandits are gonna die left and right
i can't wait
and that is when the hero who saved us
on helios died
that was when i left hanson jack's
employ
you regret teaming up with jack yes
now do what you will
kill her what no if it weren't for
people like her our friends might still
be alive
ready this ain't us lil this ain't
you fire
the hell
now is not the time for victory
wall is coming and you will need
all the voltages you can get